you are fortunate to have the
opportunity for instance your student in
college you have third year abroad or
you have the summer internship program
or you've just graduated take the chance
go to a poor country go to a village
learn about life as it's lived by
billions of people on the planet see the
challenges see the solutions but don't
let the pundits who know so little
filter this reality for you go in and
experience it it will change your life
you'll understand things more clearly
you'll remain committed for life to
helping to improve the situation in the
world especially for the poorest of the
poor you'll understand the nature of
finding real solutions and no doubt that
you'll make a major change in the years
ahead